we cannot see
very far in front of us that's why we
have to act ethically you know there is
something called situationalism in
ethics which is where you say i'm going
to do a
because if i do a
b c and d will result
well this is a very flawed form of
thinking you never do a because b c and
d will result you do a because a should
be done
and nothing can be known
about the results
but it seems and i want to i want if
last night seemed somewhat tinged with
hopelessness or with concern
it's only a passing mood the real
fact of the matter is i think
that
the
tools for transformation are now in
place it's only our impatience
which makes it difficult
the uh
the situation with
atomic weapons is going to be the
watershed and the first place where i
expect to see it and in the solving of
that problem
we will realize what has happened to us
we will realize that it is through the
feminine
that the technical exploration of matter
is now ended or at least can no longer
be carried out on the surface of the
planet there may be
yet greater release of energy and star
drives and these sorts of things but
essentially having arrived at the
sub-quark level
i don't see another thousand years of
involvement in elucidating the mysteries
of elementary matter
we have discovered at the edge of the
mysteries of elementary matter the human
mind
and even those
physicists are willing to grant this at
this point so at the edge of the human
mind that's a feminine ocean and to sail
across it to swim in it we have to
re-engineer as people and cultures
now as a male
the way i
attempt to re-engineer myself for it
is by taking psychedelics because they
are psycholytic
on
the
male
inherited ideological structure and
worldview
i mean i was a scientist or headed for a
career in science
and certainly thought that that was how
you
talked about reality if you were serious
but now i see that
only very trivial realities can be
talked about scientifically and it is
satisfying to talk about trivial
realities it's wonderful to have a page
of equations that balance there's a
thrill
to that and when they match data that's
even more thrilling but these are cheap
thrills in the context of the cultural
crisis
that we're in
the mother
which is the a signifier
for the over
soul
of the feminine
must be
made become
the sterility
of the feminine
must end
it's a sterility that has been induced
by the male
withholding
of the historical context for solution
if you will
and when it does end and it is ending
the feminine will as it always does give
birth
to something and
as in all births
the child is not visible until the birth
is completed nor
ordinarily are the pertinent details
about it like even its sex
so that out of the foment of the
feminine will come the alchemical child
at the end of time
and the alchemical child at the end of
time is not
a person it is
a hyper object of some sort or perhaps
it is the first person but it can only
at this point be talked about in
mystical terms it is the flying saucer
it is the christ resurrected it is the
messiah
it is all of these things but it is it
transcends them they are
unsatisfying glosses on it but when it
comes it will be recognized and the
curious mythologies of the millennium
that we can trace back into
post-exilic
judaism
will then be seen to be
simply reflections
anticipations
of
the event at the end of time
almost as though
someone last night mentioned holography
one of the things about holography is
that information
is embedded at all points
simultaneously so that if you have a
small part of a hologram you can usually
get the image out
but the more the larger the piece of the
hologram that you have the higher the
definition
of the image
so what i think we're getting in the
careers of people like christ and
muhammad and this sort of thing
are
small pieces of the total hologram
there will be a resolution at the end of
the world there will be a second coming
there will be a lifting up a separating
out they have the right idea they have
the outlines
of what it is but they that's what being
a prophet is but the real fact of the
matter will exceed
the prophecy reality outruns
apprehension it says in moby dick
reality certainly will outrun
apprehension more and more and the
the flying saucer at the end of time the
birth of the alchemical child out of the
global feminism
is the culmination of the masculine
alchemy carried on through history being
fused with the shamanic gnosis that has
been maintained by shamans men and women
all over the world
since pre-history
[Music]
you